hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the World Youth under-18
championship it's pregnant on the vs.
India's 61st grandmaster indian p and
well it's it's a really interesting game
and we are enjoying the game of games of
the eyelid manchester diamond but we
also have to mention this as it is quite
an achievement for young prabhu so
without further ado let's just check it
out it's it's a 77 player swiss
tournament so pregnant there's only 14
years old and he's competing in the
under-18 World Youth Championship so
really exciting the the tournament is
taking place in Mumbai India and the
time control is nineteen ninety minutes
per player and after 40 moves you of
course reach time control and you are
awarded additional 30 minutes plus you
get 30 seconds increment starting from
move 1 so without further ado let's
check it out program that with the white
pieces opens with efore with b6 Indian
goes for the Pierce defense and now d4
we have g6 and now Knight to f3 Bishop
to g7 and now Bishop to c4 so all all
fairly standard with a6 castles by
pregnant and in the now Knight to f6 and
here is something that I want to mention
here I would say okay there is a there
is a game where each sex was played
there is also a game where beef beef I
was played but tonight f6 is a new move
in the position and as a move 5 we have
a completely new game so it's something
I would usually say but something
happened in the previous video where I
mentioned that it's a new game as I've
moved this and someone mentioned in the
comments that it's actually not that a
few more moves were played and are known
so I decided to check out if the the
database I was using so far was was
correct maybe you know it doesn't
contain all the games so I paid $5.00
for for access to official chests based
database where it they claim to be the
biggest
database for chess games in the world
and I decided to put this to a test so
in my in the database I was using so far
Knight to f6 is a new move in the
position but in the chess based database
there are a few more moves played for
example quinta e2
this is how the game continued this is
what Prager played he's preparing a five
and he doesn't want the Queen here so if
there's a trade in the center
he doesn't have to trade Queens with
castles by black sorry about that
castles by black and now II five here of
course black doesn't want to trade with
Knight back to e8 and h3 now by Prague
and here Knight the c6 is a known move
in the chess based database but it is
only as of move c6 that we have a
completely new game
however c6 is a move that was played in
90 c6 instead of c6 was a move that was
played in two games between 2100 players
and there is one game where 2500 player
played against a a 1900 player so they
are not how to put it notable games from
top tier tournaments so III paid for
that $5.00 and I will now have access to
the chest base database for for a month
so I will also be using both of my
databases to you know reference the
moves but I don't think if it doesn't
show itself useful I will go back to
using my old database because even if
it's not a new move as I usually say in
the previous videos I would usually say
only use references from notable games
from top-tier tournaments and from
really strong grandmasters but as I as I
do have access to it now I will also be
referencing it so just wanted to mention
that and thank you for mentioning it in
the previous video that the database may
not be fully fully correct but okay c6
and now it is definitely as a move 8
that we have a completely new game we
looked at e1 by Prague continuing
development and now Knight the c7 with
Nightbeat the d2 by pregnant and now you
could go for b5 here pushing the bag
Bishop to e6 is an interesting idea but
here we're Knights to d7 allowing Prague
to go for a very interesting pawn push
in the center of course which is e 6
this is what product us with F captures
Bishop captures with check King to h8
and now Bishop back the b3 opening up an
attack towards the e7 pawn and here
black plays east 6 now here's the
question can the d6 pawn be captured not
really
if you could capture it it would be
great but if you captured rook e8 and
how do you how do you stop black from
capturing it you could go Queen c4 but
then just d5 or or even better nights
the b6 opening up an attack towards the
bishop and also the Queen on c4 Queen
would have to move and then you just
pick up the piece so you cannot capture
the pawn here with Knight to c4 by
Prague in the d6 pawn is under attack
so either the knight moves or you push
it to d5 Indian pushes it to d5 and now
we have Bishop to g5 first attacking the
Queen here the shot blocks check a
mission block the attack on the Queen
Bishop captures Queen captures and only
now Knight to e5 where there's no Bishop
to challenge the night here and if this
Knight captures it then just this Knight
takes its place and well we do have a
monster night in the center of the board
so Knights the b5 attacking the d4 pawn
and now a for pushing the knight back
Rema nuvaring the Knights the d6 from
where it can come to e4 but it can stay
Annie for very long as white will
definitely activate the bishop at some
point you will play c3 Bishop to c2 and
the night will not have a very safe
outpost on e4 so C 3 by Prague oh you
have to activate this Bishop this way
and now as I said Knight to e4 isn't
really doing anything since Bishop is
coming to see to a5 by black with Bishop
to c2 by pregnant Monda and then now
comes Queen to g7 with h4 and now Knight
to f5 that that's an excellent night and
if white wants to get rid of it you will
either have to give up your very strong
lights for a bishop or push g4 which at
the moment could be a too much weakening
of the king side so here Knight back to
d3 this Knight is now coming to f4 from
where it can help out with the attack of
the backwards e 6 pawn with Knight to f6
and here just Knight to f4 as planned
with Queen to c7 a grabbing hold of the
e5 square and now comes Knight to e5 so
if you look at this position
even before Knights the e5 here the
knight on f4 is under attack and how do
you defend it there are a few moves you
could try like a g3 right away but
pregnant Honda decides the
to defend his night with attacked he
played not a tactic but with an idea
he plays Knight to e5 now the Queen
cannot capture on f4 but also the knight
is no longer guarding the h4 pawn
so can Indian capture the h4 point well
he kind of can and he also can't he
decided to capture it but other than
that what move is there how do you
develop further develop the Queen what
where are these nice going what's the
route can FA doing this Bishop doesn't
really have a bright future and unless
the bishop gets a bright future this
rook really has no good square so here
Knight captures on h4 grabbing a pawn
and now
Prager goes g3 pushes the knight back
and now King to g2 and now by giving up
this pawn he gets the semi open H file
to use for his attack with g5 attacking
the knight Knight to g6 check giving up
the two knights for for this broken f8
doesn't really do anything
black will very easily defend against
all the threats along the H file so just
nice to h5 here Prague once probably
once Knight captures Queen captures and
after the Queen comes to help up with
the defense now rook the h1 it's just a
very ugly position for black you still
have problems developing Bishop d7 if
you if you want to go for a blush of the
yet just rook h2 you will double up
rooks on the H file Bishop e8 you will
bring the Queen back and now this rope
is coming to h1 and it will be very hard
for black to keep on defending this
so after Knight h5 Indian prevents this
exchange he goes Knights to eat and now
rook the h1 now probably is preparing to
double up rooks along the H file King to
g8 you don't want your King on the same
file as the rooks Knight to g6 will come
at some point after of course the night
from h5 move so King to g8 but now
Knight to g4 with some the tricky ideas
of capturing on f5 in the a followed by
Knight to h6 check so what do you play
here how do you how do you defend this
you could go back with the King that's
just admitting your previous move was it
was a bad one and you didn't really have
all that much to play on the previous
move either
so here black continues with c5 you know
it is a principle idea when your
opponent is attacking and the King said
you should strike in the center but here
it's a
just a bit too slow Queen to d2 by
Prague going after the g5 pawn Indian
defense at Queen to d8 and now comes
Luke 8 e 1 putting the rope to the
semi-open efile going for that that
weakness that is the e6 pawn we have
Knight eat the g7 now offering a trade
sorry not not not night after g7 night e
to g7 offering a trade and here probable
welcomes this trade with Knight captures
King captures in the now rook to h5
preparing to double roofs but also with
a double attack against the g5 points so
Indian defense at age 6 and now just
rook eat the h1 with a triple attack on
the h6 pawn with rook to e8 the
defending it and now Queen e2 going for
this Queen to e5 check this will greatly
improve the activity of the Queen so
Indian defense at the Queen to c7 and
now comes well everything is now set in
motion I don't even have to tell you
what Prague played now there's a triple
attack on the h6 pawn there's also a
triple defense towards the h6 pawn so
here Prague will just removed one of the
defenders as now everything in the
position is nicely set Bishop captures
an f5 congratulations on finding that I
know y'all saw it he captures an f5 and
now Knight captures an h6 just grabbing
that pawn and now with the H file fully
open there really isn't all that much to
do with King to g6 but now white is
completely winning so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the quickest
way to victory for white well I give you
a couple of seconds no need to discuss
your family over dinner on this one so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding the easiest
path to victory and for those of you who
just want Angel show its Knight to f7
just opening up and attack towards the
rook so now if King captures you will
just capture this rook when this rook
lines on h7 it's game over
and if you don't after this night to
have several move I also want to mention
that after night we have seven Indian
resigned to the game and probably one
very nice 38 move miniature and you know
if of course you go for row characters
they're just Queen captures on h5 which
check also guards the knight King of 6
Queen h8 check now if King captures just
rookie
seven will easily be winning and if King
e6 you'll go Queeny Queeny eight check
Queen blocks and now rooked h8 is mate
because the pawn covers this square and
there is there is nowhere to go so
really a really an awesome game bye-bye
young problem taking down the the
under-18 World Youth Championship being
for 14 years old himself 14 here is
young himself which is a very impressive
and quite an achievement definitely a
bright future to young Trago
and it really this game just showed how
powerful he is with the white pieces
black had no counter play at all okay
it's a it's never easy to play the pity
defense against a very strong
Grandmaster but here it just seemed a
bit too easy how probably completely
tied down blacks pieces this Bishop and
rook never saw the light of day and even
if you gave black I think even if you
get black like three moves in row it
wouldn't be enough to make make it count
so really exciting program Ananda wins
it with 911 so without a single loss and
he claims it with soul first the second
place was eight and a half points so
really just crushing the field a
wonderful achievement and I offer my
congratulations to a young Prague on
being such a such a great player so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Peter Shafto for a
contribution to my channel and thank you
a lot I really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Isle of Man chess tournament
checking up in your suggestions such as
this one here and of course searching on
everything that happens in the chess
world so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day